wir arbeiten eigentlich prinz akkaya
diesen fünf den können wir jetzt über
die schulter schauen bei ihrer naja
sagen wir mal arbeit und zwar dank den
fahndungsfotos der berliner polizei wir
sehen sie hier bei der arbeit ja hier
wird knack knack mit dem brecheisen
mehrere schließfächer aufgehebelt die
fünf täter sind kräftig beschäftigt und
schließlich arbeiten sie vor allem
antiken schmuck
der haken an der geschichte ist diese
fünf laufen immer noch frei herum und
deswegen bittet die polizei jetzt auch
um ihre mithilfe also wenn ihnen einer
dieser fünf panzerknacker bekannt
vorkommen
dann rufen sie doch diese nummer an die
wir hier jetzt gerade eingeblendet haben
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren